it's time for roses and Rose a with
Chardonnay hi you guys we are about to
get down with hometowns everybody i'm
lauren zima here to recap the hometowns
episode of our Eli and Ike junior season
of The Bachelor and I've got Chardonnay
instead of Rose day today because let's
be honest isn't Chardonnay the first
type of wine that you've seriously drink
with your own mother
shoutout to my mom
Donna here's to you but here's what you
should not do and that's drink every
time the same word is said in this
episode we'd all be on the floor right
along with Kendall's dead animals so
yeah this is gonna be the night of don't
drink when because it would be too
dangerous so Ari starts the episode
strong with this quote this is been such
an amazing journey so far it's crazy to
think do not drink every time he says
crazy in this episode crazy I'm crazy
about it don't do it it's crazy you
think that we started with 29 women and
now there's four women left is it that
crazy or is it simple math based on the
formula of this reality show and the
number of episodes per season one of
these women is going to be my wife
really I was shocked he said that you
guys how does he know that I guess I
could get fiance one of them is going to
be your fiance you intend to propose but
one of them is going to be more one
that's a sense of confidence that I'm
not sure I feel comfortable with
you know what here's what we're gonna do
safely and responsibly drink every time
you felt confused this is a huge week
because it's hometowns
yes this is the season of stating the
obvious and then we're gonna start
things off with Kendall to which he says
animal is not your average girl she's
very interesting well what does that say
about most of us all right anyway she's
Courtney quirky qu IR KY quirky would
mean odd Corki
cor KY wouldn't mean the thing that was
in this before I opened it with the joy
of an unbridled innocent child and don't
drink every time he says Corki cuz he
keeps on saying it Corki nobody corrects
it Corki again I'm confused ari says I'm
crazy about her
so I'm just so excited that we have all
day today it's been too long but one
thing I feel great about you guys is
that Kendall's taxidermy has tax or
return D it's back to us and it's real
here's the thing I was at the women tell
all taping last week
shameless blog and I interviewed a bunch
of the ladies and Becca em told me that
no the taxidermy is a real thing that
her and kennel hang out cuz they both
live in LA and that Kendall has stuffed
in for home and we saw them they went to
a warehouse for this date she tweeted I
have a little shout out to the warehouse
she doesn't live in that warehouse but
we learned things like you know that
taxidermy doesn't have to just be stiff
animal they're stuffed what it can be
stuffed animals which is so weird
and then
love his Kendall head re do some
taxidermy with her okay this is great a
hometown date is supposed to be about
actually getting to know you and this is
what Kendall really likes to do so we
are going to be mounting rep oh God
stuff dead rats of all the animals a
[Laughter]
little terrified I mean I would guess
that she picked rats based on the size
and the ease of which they could stuff
them in a short amount of time but not
even mice not even cute little mice we
had to do rats
oh my gosh this is some sounds and the
lamb stuff again are he said I was like
you know your low Corky a lot of
cellular telephone and lookup synonyms
for a word kooky nutty silly rocky batty
bonkers coo coo describe Burkina Kenda
so Kendall's taxidermy is real and we
confirmed kendall has a twin sister
named Kylie so your sister she's your
identical twin mm-hmm and guys what does
it say about Arie that when Kendall told
him she had a twin sister named Kylie my
sister Kylie that he had no reaction
that was worse than episode one when he
didn't acknowledge Tia's Wiener joke you
know yeah
please tell me you don't already have a
little wiener I do not have this Ari I
mean I know you're old you got the
cardigans you're sailing off with the
Sun but come on they're the Kardashians
keep up
I do worry like if she could fall for me
and again I wonder you guys if our ease
insecurity about whether a woman
actually likes him is going to be the
hinge on which this final decision turns
I don't know if a hinge turns but you
see I'm saying I think that it might be
what his decision comes down to because
he clearly can fall for a woman he's
fallen for him all fallen for a male
he's confusing us with how quickly he's
falling and we thought he was really
into Lauren B last week he said he was
ready to love her and now you know he
really likes Kendall so I'm so confused
and I wonder if in the end it's just
gonna be about who is making their
feelings clearest to him I think that he
both likes to play hard-to-get
and then that he also just think really
needs you to say it should like him and
love him and I'm not used to being
vulnerable Kendall goes on about how she
isn't used to being vulnerable and she
can't open up and these are problems you
know we've heard before so again don't
drink anytime anybody says vulnerable
then to Weiner Arkansas for Tia's dates
I love Tia's family Tia's dad called
Ariary Tia's older brother is an
intimidating fellow he looks like he's
ready to take down Ari and take down an
army and then Tia's dad was the first of
several dads to threaten Ari and he said
you know he said something like if you
hurt her I can find you on Google I'll
find you on Google don't even get me
started on Bing Ask Jeeves is a whole
nother level
I love this guy Tia tells Ari that she
loves him I know it's hard that I can't
express like every single feeling that I
have that again I'm confused
are you implying you're in love with TIA
I thought you for sure were like I'm in
love with Lauren B although he did say
he falls in love with two women maybe
more than two then we go to Becca she's
in Minnesota even though it seems like
Washington cuz it's all about couples
maybe I don't know enough about
Minnesota but don't drink every time
Becca and Arie say apples JC what's the
French word for Apple Oh Bom Bom okay JC
there are no potatoes here not I know
people say I didn't pay attention in
geography history as we know Becca's
father had passed away many years ago
and I thought that Arie actually handled
this conversation with Becca's scary
uncle Gary pretty well uncle Gary Oh
Gary
uncle Gary really cares about Becca he
teared up in the convo re really
sensitively as JC has pointed out he's
an empath really sensitively like I
think felt this family's very real and
still tangible pain and she listened and
it was a really solid moment for Arie to
show that he has this good core I liked
it
oh-oh-oh but then Ari tells uncle Gary
who is a pastor but he and Bek I had had
to talk about religion how can I have
talked about this spiritually I'm not as
far along as she is they did I would
love to see that conversation it sounds
substantial so much more substantial
than much of what we've seen this season
sorry it's not warmer right now okay can
we please see a discussion a debate on
the state of religion then we go on to
Lauren B and we're gonna ride some
horses Lauren B's in Virginia Beach with
her family
this was interesting to me because again
hometowns are supposed to be about
getting to know someone Lauren B they
rode horses on the beach they literally
rode horses on the beach what you would
think is a date the bachelor producers
lovingly planned I don't understand this
I don't get it Lauren B what do you like
to do I want to know what you like to do
I want to know what I really like to do
does this mean they're perfect for each
other
oh my god we don't know that
we got a silhouette kiss you can drink
during this we're averaging like one per
episode and then we find our common
ground of Lauren B and re they're eating
some crab on the beach and she gets to
cheesy jokes in one right after the
other
break a leg tonight and you know Ari
loves those dad jokes so again are they
perfect for each other
think about it okay they go home to meet
her family and Ari gets up and leaves
again he's in the middle of a date with
Lauren B and he is who famously sweating
you guys if you watched when we recapped
Emily Maynard season of The Bachelorette
I always talked about how sweaty are you
looked being dabbed off he's shaking out
his shirt this guy's nervous he wasn't
like this on the other dates as far as
we could see he really likes Miss Lauren
beat so then Ari and Lauren B's dad have
a pretty placid conversation does it
normally this one this time of year or
is it
you know I was lucky it's not can't
write this stuff cuz you wouldn't but
Lauren B's dad goes from zero to 100 in
about five seconds flat he starts to say
that Ari needs to be able to protect his
daughter with his life and he's not
wrong and if Ari doesn't protect Lauren
B with his life John we've had some
great parents in the history of the
bachelor franchise everybody in the
great long and prestigious line we've
had Joe Joe's champagne drinking mom
Eric bigger spunky aunt Brian Abba solos
drinking mom and perhaps and perhaps
most famously Rachel's absent father who
we never saw and now add to that line
Lauren B's murder threatening death I
love it
then we see this really sweet moment
between Lauren B and her mom which like
made me miss my own mom Donna I honestly
like I've never felt the same way about
anyone and Lauren B is crying and saying
that she has never felt this way that
she feels like she just knows re that
they are the same that she knows what
he's thinking that they are the same and
Lauren B's mom says I do I see the way
you guys look at each other's that's
weird for me I don't think I've ever
seen you and another person look at each
other like that before it's just that I
want this to be explained I want to know
what it is that connects the two of them
so strongly because they both talked
about this connection but maybe that's
the whole thing is that it's just a
connection maybe we are in the presence
of the most pure love that this
franchise has ever known or seen
witchcraft fate whatever you want to
call it maybe this is it you guys the
real stuff that they've always told us
about love at first sight love at first
just love I don't know I'm confused
side notice anybody else notice that
Kendall has a really strange cadence to
the way she speaks confidence but then I
know there are things that we need to
talk about and I love it what she kind
of guys is like pause after short words
and speed through long words they're all
at the rose ceremony and Kendall goes
and I don't want this relationship to
end I don't want this relationship Jen I
love Kendall she's Corki Lauren B again
says she loves Ari they've connected on
a different level the level of thinny
and Becca says she loves Ari and Tia
says she loves Ari I think Kendall is
the only one who hasn't said that she
loves Ari but guess what
and no can I talk to you sure Kendall
and Ari have a moment during the rose
ceremony where he pulls her aside he
must speak to her and Tia says
[Music]
and yes yeah the answer is yes and
Becca's like I don't know but no we do
know and the answer is yes again that's
how the show works and then Ari comes
back and he sends Tia home and it's so
sad you guys cuz she's even in a white
dress
I mean Wow the irony what perhaps the
planning so Tia zags it really broke my
heart her tears sounds so real and it
was painful and I spoke to her about
whether she'd want to talk to Ari again
after all this and how she feels about
her journey on the show
that's a petty T online.com you know
what that was not not of course that our
he's gonna be able to explain why he's
sending Tia home he's just says that
quote there's something missing
something that he has with Lauren B okay
you guys so we are winding things down
who do you think that re is going to
choose at this point
Kendal's you know we have Kendall who
says things like I'm kind of face walls
I don't even know existed and it's hard
to find them if you don't know where
they are
Wow actually can I get JC in here for a
minute
JC again we need your quasi psychiatric
take this time on our favorite Corky gal
Kendall JC what do we like about our
quirky gal Kendall you know she said she
had a hard time expressing her feelings
but that's expressing your feelings I
like that kind of self-reflection
self-expressing JC so if you guys need
me I'll be in the pit of confusion
wondering what's gonna happen from here
we have kind of a quirky schedule coming
up here women tell all is going to air
this Sunday Sunday followed by an
episode of The Bachelor on Monday night
and of course make sure to check out
winter games on three
I interviewed that cast as well it's all
coming to you soon
much love you guys thank you so much
here's to Donna she taught me well bye
again everybody JC is here with his
quasi psychiatric take on our favorite
quirky gal Kendall oh and you wear your
headphones this time
oh no it's me that's but that's the
presence of our EMR bees left